-Jurnee Smollett,
you look gorgeous!
-Oh, thank you!
-Thank you for being here!
-I'm so excited to
actually be in person.
-In person! We met on Zoom!
-Yeah, man.
-Thank you for being here.
-You're alive. You're real.
-Yeah, I'm a real person.
I'm a real boy.
-He's real!
-I've got a real beard
and everything.
-Yeah, this is cool.
-I want to ask --
I know you just finished
filming with Jamie Fox?
-Yeah.
-He's one of our friends.
He's just the greatest,
right? To work with.
-I mean, dream come true, man.
-And fun, talented.
-Just so much fun.
So generous as an actor,
you know?
We did a film a few months ago
called "The Burial,"
and we played litigators
and we played enemies.
I play his adversary,
and I didn't meet him
until the day
we were supposed to shoot.
Like, literally no rehearsal,
walk on set.
You're like, alright.
I'd been in the library
for months and courtrooms,
studying law and trying to
do all my research.
And he and I, we do this scene,
we go at it,
And I'm thinking,
we're gonna be method.
He's gonna be my enemy, man.
And then after
we finish the scene,
he comes up
and gives me a big hug.
He's like,
"Jurnee, you killed it!"
And I was like, Oh, my God.
-It makes you cry.
You go, "I'm in love with you."
-I melted!
I was like,
this guy is the coolest man.
-He's a charming man.
-He's one of the greatest actors
of all time to me, so...
-I love him.
-"Django," right?
-Come on. Everything.
He's unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-And also, you have
another co-star in that film,
your five-year-old son, Hunter.
How did that come about?
-Our director, Maggie Betts,
called me, and she's like,
"Jurnee, we've auditioned
so many kids,
and I just need a smart kid."
And my son, Hunter --
I know parents always think
their children are smart.
However,
my son is five years old
and he's reading and doing math
on the third grade level.
-Wow.
-So he's really smart.
And he wants to be
a paleontologist.
He wants to bring the dinosaurs
back from extinction.
-Oh, no way.
-Yeah, yeah.
We're working on it.
-Hunter, do that, buddy.
-Maggie is like, "Can Hunter
be in this scene with Jamie?"
And I'm like, "Oh, I don't post
him on social media,
but, you know, if he's ever
gonna do something in film,
I mean, like...
-Put him in a movie.
-With Jamie Foxx!
I mean, this is epic.
You know? Like, he can do this.
-That's funny.
-And so, he rehearses his
two lines for a month
leading up to the scene, right?
He's like,
"I'm gonna be prepared."
And we get there, I'm like,
"Oh, my gosh, baby.
Look at the call sheet.
Your name is on the call sheet."
He looks at it and he goes,
"Why am I number 67?"
[ Laughter ]
I snatch the call sheet from him
and he's like,
"Well, who's number one?"
I say,
"Jamie Foxx, Oscar winner."
And he says,
"Well, who's number two?"
And I say, "Tommy Lee Jones.
You know, legend, icon."
And he says,
"Well, who's number three?"
And I say,
"Mommy is number three."
And he looks at me
and he's like,
"So I'm number 67, and
you're number three?"
-No! Whoa.
-I was like, "Kid...
you're never, ever acting,
ever again."
Like, stick with
the paleontology.
-I know you star in films,
but this is your first movie
that you're starring in
and executive producing.
-Yeah.
-This is a big deal.
"Lou." Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did you get involved
with this now?
Allison Janney?
-Yeah, Allison Janney,
she's such an icon.
At 61 years old --
you guys gotta see this film.
She's kicking butt,
doing all her own stunts.
It's really amazing.
It's produced by J.J. Abrams
and Bad Robot,
and it's a fun film, you know?
It's an intense thriller
in which two women have to
go on this rescue mission
to rescue a little girl
who's been kidnapped,
my character's daughter.
And we come from very
different backgrounds
and are forced to work together
even though
we kind of hate each other.
-Yeah.
And while you're filming this,
you get the news that you were
nominated for an Emmy.
-Yeah.
-Wow, this is cool,
that' everything's
happening right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And after you find out you're
getting nominated and you go,
"Oh, my gosh,
I'm so excited I got nominated,
this is awesome,"
Allison Janney
gets nominated for an Emmy.
The same day!
-I know, but she didn't know.
I'm in the makeup trailer
and I get the call.
I'm screaming.
It's my first time being
nominated for an Emmy.
-Of course.
-She comes over and she's like,
"What's the matter?"
And I'm like,
"I got nominated for an Emmy!"
She's like, "Hell yeah, you did.
I voted for you."
-That's what friends are for.
-Yeah!
I run out of the trailer.
I call my family.
My brother tells me,
"You know, your co-star
got nominated as well."
I was like, "I was just
in the trailer with her!"
And so I go on set
to rehearse,
and I'm like, "Congratulations!"
She says, "For what?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"You got nominated for 'Mom.'"
And she's like,
"Shut up, shut up. No way."
[ Laughter ]
-You're like,
"Let's just party! Let's go!"
-Dude, it's like,
her 17th nomination.
-She's a legend.
-It was my first, so, you know.
-Yeah, come on.
-She's such a legend.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jurnee Smollett
and Allison Janney in "Lou."
Take a look at this.
-Her father took her.
-Her father?
-Uh-huh. He's -- He's here.
How the hell is he here?
-Hold on, you saw him?
-No, I -- He --
He's supposed to be dead,
but he found us.
I thought -- I thought
we were free of him.
He killed Chris.
-Jesus Christ.
-Where are your keys?
My car won't start.
I've got to get to the sheriff.
-I'll drive.
[ Keys jingling ]
[ Thunder cracks ]
[ Engine sputters ]
-Hmm.
[ Engine splutters ]
-Come on, come on.
[ Thunder cracks ]
♪♪
[ Children's melody playing ]
-What's wrong?
-Run!
-Whoa!
[ Applause ]
-Jurnee Smollett, everyone!
"Lou" is streaming now
on Netflix.